We are cleared for landing in Gridiron Heights
Welcome back to football, everyone
You like that?
YOU LIKE THAT?!!!
We remind you this is a non-smoking league
Doing great, Ice Man
Just got to land this bad boy like we've practiced
a thousand times before
No problem, Coach
Can you give me a read on the approach vectors?
Looks like we're turning from 28 degrees west
Uh, heading towards 3 degrees
That's 28 to 3
What's that?
28 to 3
And perfect conditions
There's no way you could screw this landing up
Yeah, totally
Uh Ice?  You all right?
Matty! Matty! Matty Ice! Ice Man! You good?!
OH GOD. He’s chooooooking!!! He’s chooooking!
My ankle!
Ow, my shoulder! No one’s fault, no one’s fault, tho
Is there a quarterback who can land this plane?
Oh, no, sorry.  Like a real quarterback
Sounds like a job for...
Smokin' Jay
Out of my way scrub
I got this
Um, let's see
Ow, hurt my thumb; I'm done, I give up